[Music]
me review anyone remember this show yeah
I remember funny pictures on the
internet time are you excited
what are the memes let's just jump into
it that's a dead meme cringe bro where
do we begin we have a lot of memes today
that was surprised to find out despite
meme review not being so frequent as
used to meme still exists somehow I
first meme is what I like to call simp
bed
it's the dead from Coraline the movie oh
my god such mood that's me right now
quarantine got me like quarter lines
dead Coraline Corinth Oh which is also
perfect contrast from the Aria waning
Sun meme are you winning dead now we
have the opposite of course is winning
look at him what a Chad what an alpha
right there are you winning dead every
single flippin day son every time I sit
down in front of the computer I win win
win no matter what are you winning dad
no she didn't even acknowledge my three
thousand dollar donation sorry this will
have to go from your college fund kid
didn't even look at it
cringe bro how ninja looked having to
defend his wife stupid
that is so mood are you winning dad kids
selling calm sold I think so
what's in there oh my god was there not
an old meme like this just like this oh
my god it's the same
memes have come full circle at last
stair dad
I cannot have enough of stair dad dad
I'm hungry tell your mother she's not in
the kitchen
she's what woman nothing kitchen now
that's funny I'd like to say that the
standard of comedy has increased but
let's get real here it's gone nowhere
are you winning dead easy mode is now
selectable of course I lost some purpose
so I can unlock easy mode cringe the IT
guy delayed in Google Chrome and
blocking cool math games from all the
computer that's how he looks like we
finally found the footage all those
god-awful people that needs to be thrown
into jail hint their enemy they're
strong every frame of the girls PB in
every hand time we finally found them
this is what they look like are you
winning dad yes I'm playing the last
boss of terraria on expert mode cringe
now close the door you son of a [ __ ]
how streamers look like after they hit
the end stream button yeah I can confirm
this is anyone truly ever winning if our
parents aren't winning then who's
winning I'm not you're telling your
friend win in a game because he's new
you're pretty bad at this all right meme
ception what do we got now God now no
one asks for this no Mike off did stop
and they're all goddamn memes that lived
through the decade
why does rickroll have to be the one wha
hey you can't trust anyone in today's
world turn the picture upside down and
find out what oh god what happened where
did I go well here I am
hey hey that was sympton for it gets a 4
it's not nearly as good as are you
winning there son I'll take it
I'm surprised to be sure but a welcome
one for you get the 4 I've been watching
for food worse I keep calling it fruit
I know how to rate things better now
with a little bit more criticism next
name have you ever gone to a
drive-through and food break food break
meme so we have this McDonald's where
someone someone try to order no ketchup
no dice onions no pickle no meat no
regular bun no salt boneless burger
boneless burger making a meal
the whole thing I tried ordering a
boneless burger legendary boneless
burger I want to eat you so bad please
and the entire freaking system crashed
reading the errorlog this thing didn't
just crash somehow ordering a boneless
burger forbidden boneless burger one day
I'll eat you corrupted the bootloader
amazing bug right there the thing didn't
crash it's broke it literally just hello
food food broke understandable have a
nice day
understandable completely acceptable I
suppose this is a mix of the ice cream
machine broke but now the food broke get
it I actually got it for the first time
and I've been looking at many of these I
cannot pretend that I'm smarter or
better than these memes hello food food
broke understandable have a great day
great day broke there know what you do
if they broke oh God you think you had a
bad day try day that broke cringe hello
games games broke incomprehensible have
a terrible week why you never work
Microsoft while you game crash how
schools expect us to stop bullying yours
you're bothering me please stop
understand the book have a great day
problem solve they have a great day a
hello entry cobras stan is not the real
country understandable glory to
arstotzka i understand this one because
i play the game
humans make the air vibrate with his
vocal cords other humans understandable
that's so crazy
it's too
soundwaves in different wavelengths what
hello concept of love love broke I
understand oh yeah you Zoomers don't
understand this meme don't even pretend
for once I got it and you probably did
it you dumb stinky that's right
you can have your fitness and ferb back
hello food that's my line you're in the
wrong panel Brodie mean broke understand
the bow but let's get it real next time
on my shopping be like hello hi may I
help you sir
just licking understand have a nice day
just looking the equivalent of leave me
the [ __ ] alone
alright I don't want to talk to you
hello food food machine fix finally open
WinRAR winner please buy a license me
know when they're understandable have
great day see I bought WinRAR once and
apparently you have to buy it on every
computer I'm not gonna do that
no no wind roared be like no you can't
just not pay for the license don't click
eggs
haha we'd rather go by bike it's time to
go we say a good meme no understandable
have a great day understandable have a
great day odd that's a couple good ones
in there but I think overall the whole
deep fried formula come on bruh
that's so 2017 1808 20-something yeah
three it gets a goddamn three try harder
next time
understandable have shut up shut up
alright
in meme news India banned tick tock apps
yeah in the appendix hawk epic win I
would say in the lower tick tocks rating
21.9 google removes the low rating India
bans tick tock ribbon of the city and
nothing of value was lost
how about that China when it burns
applications of other countries China
when other countries pay their what what
you get also ban tick tock that's only a
certain thing we've been tick tock when
your sister logs on the tick tock using
the home Wi-Fi now all of China knows
you're here haha I get it not that funny
though say India deletes tick-tock
read it that's hysterical each and I
tick-tock in the abeyance 59 Chinese
apps oh wait
tick-tock is Chinese I don't know that
oh it's super simulator available in
China I mean India I need to know I need
to know indian bros come on let me know
now there's a lot of great memes
regarding this event but my favorite is
59 chinese apps including tick tock lot
mark k bihar nickel dia here's some more
of my favorites harpoon nachita kiya
Joe karna hai Oh Carla sanera atma hatya
tourniquet time ah je gala hi Brian eat
to learn Indian that's awesome you can
say our gala hi and get away with it see
any other language oh you can't you say
gala that's gay bro yeah it is gay its
so gay
alright India tick-tock memes one so bad
no 10 10 out of 10 so good oh my god
baby in one's crack me up good bro hell
yeah
I'm not desperate for memes at all we
have a lot of great more memes actually
I do I did I didn't find out about this
until recently and it's goddamn
beautiful
it's lots of us memes and they're taking
the most painful scenes from the game no
spoilers I will not show of the original
and people are drawing their own fan
version of it and it's goddamn beautiful
it's probably the best thing I've ever
seen
alright here's the template very nice
it's really not that funny but it's also
very yeah is that the bunch of 87
yeah I get I get that you have to play
the game to understand these but my god
it's so good
yes the choke gang that's hysterical
well done I love this cuz he could draw
anything and anyone and anyone can do it
absolute piece of work well done well
done now I feel less bad about the whole
game honestly I don't know why I feel
much better it was such a dreary and
dark game and I don't even mind that but
it was just unnecessary
uh yes yes yes yes there's another meme
of course and I showed it before it's
the le meme name a character that went
through more pain than her outweighed
any humans and I have no math on my
screen
correct and that's a fact name a
character that went through more pain
than her oh wait are we literally
forgetting Clementine no name a
character that went through more pain
than her back when I was in high school
I wanted to approach this girl on a bus
on my way to school she was really hot
and I knew I'd regret it if I didn't
approach her there was one big problem
there was a middle-aged lady seated next
to her and I couldn't talk to this girl
without with the lady right next to her
I had to think of a quick way to get rid
of the lady and then woke up from my
seat slowly walked to the row they were
seated and calmly asked the lady excuse
me ma'am could you please let me sit
next to my sister turns out what's the
girl's mom nice well played you really
thought about that hard didn't ya
neighbor character went through more
pain that one episode of mr. Bean's I
bet you Zoomers don't understand this
one because you don't understand true
pain you just okay name one character
more pain
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we get it we get it that's
great I mean life's too bullish reskin
and in general memes I mean that's the
best thing that gets I wish I could give
that a 10 out of 10 but it gets a name
it gets a name the memes are better than
the game just watch just watch the memes
you'll feel better trust me next name
some bonus memes No
aren't you a little young to be a
rollercoaster engineer yes yes I am my
[ __ ] god why did you have to create
atrocity atrocity you're seriously going
to build a roller coaster in the
backyard yes yes I am
can this and you can't stop me Karen
should be canvas me after I take my
schizophrenia medicine my own Egypt robe
my homie Jerome no I like this book
that's my favorite one so far what do
you think oh that's great thank you for
your input that's all for this week's
name review thank you for watching do
you agree with the ratings let me know
daba daba daba Doo by do subscribe thank
you for subscribing we're trying to hit
a hundred billion subscribers
see you tomorrow gamers hey door
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten what creatures fart spells and
pull troops awaits
hope T is coming to Nintendo's wait and
remember it has a very big TV pre-order
promotion heavy
yeah yeah we a checkbook birthday girl
right away
[Music]